depuis des années seul le son de l'eau
des cascades de la cei résonnent dans la
vallée mais d'ici quelques jours le
grincement du portalet qui glisse sur
son câble va refaire surface
autour des pièces revenus de savoie les
amoureux du téléphérique sont comme des
gosses au pied du sapin en fait
elle est d'accord exactement même
certains hommes de franck une route
c'est que c'est épatant et on a connu
les pièces toutes rouillées et tout ça
ils ont vraiment bien bossé
une grammaire n'aurais pensé devoir aux
pièces aussi bien
que ça vous fait plaisir
pour nous c'était c'était fichu jamais
ont pensé pour
on
je range dans ce lit mot brûlures
ça méritait de c'est reparti pour un
moment à force de persévérance et de
conscience qu'il fallait sauver ce
monument historique unique les habitants
et leurs maires successifs ont fini par
y arriver même si bien sûr il n'y a plus
ni lait ni fromage au village
à l'heure actuelle on parle beaucoup de
patrimoine offre valorise le patrimoine
rural je pense que c'est d'autant plus
important de le faire
[Applaudissements]
nous mêmes enfants on l'a vu fonctionner
bien sûr ça agrémentaient nos eaux fin
de journée puisque on descendait au
chalet de fromagerie qui est ici on se
bagarrait pour manger l'armure à tenir
le ski reste autour des meules
lorsqu'elles sont pressés par les moules
et donc ça ça faisait partie de notre
vie au quotidien le sifflement des
paniers sur les câbles c'était vraiment
quelque chose à parler aux gens pendant
longtemps
un grincement plus émouvant que jamais
pour ceux qui ont suivi toutes les
étapes de la remise en état et qui
forcément ont une pensée pour ses aïeux
qui n'ont pas eu peur de l'aventuré il
ya plus d'un siècle
il devrait passer pour des farfelus
parce que deux personnes dans le village
qui disent on va faire un téléphérique
est bas les deux autres gens du village
devait bien se dire mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ces gars là les yeux doux il
fallait que ça marche parce que sa part
du marché des premiers coups il ya déjà
venus faire des réglages
ces deux vieilles mécaniques et sa
surveiller c'est comme comme une vieille
voiture que l'entretenir avant de sortir
et wii aura beaucoup d'entretien avant
de faire avant de faire les
démonstrations
désormais en état de marche et sécurisé
pour permettre l'accueil du public le
téléphérique portelais sera sans aucun
doute une des vedettes de l'été
jurassien c'était effectivement on
organise une fête du lait petite fête
champêtre donc il y aura démonstration
de
de fabrication de comté à l'ancienne
le but c'est quand même aussi on a quand
même des touristes ou à la période
estivale et puis même en période plus
calme mais c'est aussi le but
d'intéresser les touristes de le faire
leur faire découvrir cette cette
installation
le fonctionnement ça avait duré pendant
quatre-vingt dix ans donc on peut
espérer qu'avec les doutes le nouveau
mobilier qui vient d'être installé c'est
reparti c'est parti pour s'entendre